（以下、オーキド博士の真似）
ポォ↑ケモントレーナーの諸君！
わしじゃ。ハーキド博士じゃ
みんな元気にポケモン捕まえておるかのぉ〜〜〜
じゃが、みんなが知っている通り、
今のこの社会には、モンスターボールが無いのじゃ！
つまり われわれ人間は、
もし ポケットモンスター…縮めて“ポケモン”に
実際遭遇してしまったら
間違いなく殺されてしまう。
基本、いいやつらじゃが、
野生のポケモンに出会ってしまうと
話が別じゃ！よく考えてみなさい
われわれ人間が、ポケモンに勝てるわけがない。
じゃが！！
そんな われわれでも、ポケモンを倒す方法が
わ↑ずかにあるとしたら
そこ、しっかりと覚えていきたいもんじゃのぉ〜〜〜
というわけで今日はじゃがなぁ
モンスターボールがない今、われわれ人間が
ポケモンに出会ってしまったら、
どう対処すべきなのか教えていこうと、
思うんじゃなぁ〜〜〜
というわけで、今日オヌシらに、
ポケモンの倒し方を教えてくれる奴がおるぞっ
ハトシや〜〜〜
よろしく頼んだのじゃぞぉ〜〜〜
はい、ハーキド博士
ありがとうございます！
カメックス）ガオーーー
ここからの担当は、えー、
私 ポケモントレーナー
ハトシが、担当します！
よろしくお願いしまーす
えー、この公園は球技が禁止されていますので
モンスターボールの使用ができません。
もしこういう場所で、野生のポケモンと
出会ってしまうと、大変危険です。
野生のポケモン…は
優しい…ポケモンばかりとは限りません
カメックス）ガオーーー
突然人間と出会うことによって
驚いてしまい、
攻撃をしてくることが、よくありますので
そんな時の…対処法を、
今日はみなさんに、教えようと思います
あくまで護身用なので
あの、自分の身を守るための方法に過ぎません！
えー、この方法で
必ず、自分の身をポケモンから守れるという保証は、
ありませんので
えー、ご了承のほう、
よろしくお願い致します！
カメックス）ガオーーー
かなりの確率で、その、
野生のポケモンを気絶、
または絶命に追い込むことができますので
えー、その隙に
えー、近所のポケモントレーナー
または警察の方に連絡してください！
それでは、見ていきましょう！
どうぞ！
カメックス）ガオーーー
ハーキド博士）おおっと、あれはとかげポケモンの
ヒトカゲじゃなぁ…ほのおタイプじゃぞ？
ハーキド博士）冷静に考えると、
炎を吹かれると丸焦げじゃ、死んでしまうぞぉ！
くっ……ここまでか…
ハーキド博士）だがポケモン図鑑にはこう書いてある
ハーキド博士）「うまれたときから
しっぽに ほのおが ともっている。
ハーキド博士）ほのおが きえたとき
その いのちは おわってしまう。」
ハーキド博士）簡単じゃのぉ〜〜
ハーキド博士）ヒトカゲのシッポにめがけて
水をかけるのじゃっ
ハーキド博士）そうすると、
ヒトカゲは絶命してしまうぞぉ！
ハーキド博士）これにて、一件落着じゃぁ〜〜〜
ハーキド博士）おっと、続いては
ビリリダマじゃのう！
ハーキド博士）このポケモン、見た目は丸いが
油断してはならんぞ！
ハーキド博士）大爆発して
普通に死んでしまうぞぉ！
ハーキド博士）なので簡単じゃ
ハーキド博士）ビリリダマが大爆発するまで
蹴り飛ばすのじゃ！
ハーキド博士）なんとか死ぬことだけは
逃れられるんじゃなぁ〜〜〜
ハァッ
ハーキド博士）おっと続いてのポケモンは
コイキングじゃのぉ！
ハーキド博士）さかなポケモン
みずタイプのポケモンじゃ
ハーキド博士）ただの鯉に見えるが、
実際、ばかでかくて超怖いぞぉ！
ハーキド博士）はねる ですら危ないかもしれんぞぉ！
ハーキド博士）コイキングの倒し方は、
ちょっと時間がかかるかもしれんが
ハーキド博士）こういったみずタイプの ポケモンで、
ハーキド博士）見ての通り
外でピチピチ跳ねておるのじゃ
ハーキド博士）なので、一定の時間
放置しておくことによって
ハーキド博士）乾燥させるのじゃ
ハーキド博士）そうすることによって
干からびて ひんし状態まで
ハーキド博士）追い込むことができるのじゃっ
ハーキド博士）これにて、一件落着じゃのぉ〜〜〜
ハァァッ
うわ！うわうわうわうわ！！
ハーキド博士）おっと、続いてのポケモンは
エアームドじゃな？
でっか！！うわ！うわ！うわ！
ハーキド博士）人間だと触れるだけで
死んでしまうじゃなぁ。(迫真)
ハーキド博士）こーれは絶対絶命じゃと
思いたいところじゃがっ
ハーキド博士）正面からエアームドを見てみるんじゃ
ハーキド博士）こいつ正面に
目がないんじゃなぁー(哀れみ)
エアームド）ﾋﾟﾛﾋﾟｨｰ
ハーキド博士）つまりじゃ！今このエアームド、
ハトシの位置がわかってないから
ハーキド博士）ゆっくり ゆっくりと
ハーキド博士）エアームドの視界に入らないように
真っ正面に詰め寄ることによって
ハーキド博士）エアームドの近くまで
近寄ることが可能なのじゃなぁ〜〜
ハーキド博士）そうして、そのまま脳天チョップ。
一発でひんし状態じゃ！！
だぁーーん！！！
エアームド）ﾋﾟﾛﾋﾟｨｰ
[通常ED]